good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on friday
fun fun fun fun looking forward to
claudia's birthday
let's just breeze right past that okay
hey jax how you doing welcome to the
morning toast i'm darn good can't
believe it's friday it's so joyful we
feel i feel undeserving of this friday
because we all got monday off for july
4. claudia friday is friday no matter
how you slice it that's unbelievably
true and it's not subjective and even if
you didn't work on monday like it's
still friday yes but don't you feel like
when a friday comes around and it's been
like a five-day hard-earned work week
like you feel so good about it yes but i
still feel good even though this was a
four day work week we were working so
meetings meetings meetings podcast
podcast podcast photo shoot photo shoot
photo shoot modeling modeling modeling
i'm
mentally and physically exhausted from
being on set as a model yesterday we did
a second photo shoot that we can't wait
to show you guys it's not a secret
project or anything it's just like us
being models and it's not a big deal no
modeling for the greatest company on the
planet society it's society the pictures
are so so extremely cute the stripes
brothers were on set the strike brothers
were there jackie was there ben was
there claudia was there was a family
affair
there was so much spread there was cakes
let's not spoil you know the mood board
for everyone but it was really sickening
it was really sickening and that's just
a reminder that if you're heading into
this weekend you need to hydrate
yourself with the spritz society it's a
good time it's a delicious time
it's a taste of summer i don't want to
bring the mood down but i have to share
a rather haunting experience from
my bedroom last night okay
so i'm up
it's late ben's asleep oh i heard you
couldn't sleep i couldn't sleep mostly
because i just finished this like
incredible book
which was a rach parcell recommendation
called crossing the line by lucy score
and if you're saying rach parcell read
this this book yes and like i put it off
for a while and i i shouldn't have
because i [ __ ] loved it and there's a
sequel
so i bought the sequel but i was like
i'll start it tomorrow but i was just
like up at night like the book left on a
cliffhanger so i was just up late like
tossing turning should i read should i
not read i read a little and then i'm
like it's late i need to go to bed
what's late for you
late for me is like 11 30 okay but this
was like 1 30. oh okay okay that's a
late period i had tossed i had turned i
had tried i counted sheep all that [ __ ]
did you try meditating no you should
have so you should have i was just like
checking my phone like before bed like
making sure like in the two hours that i
was tossing and turning like nothing
happened
when all of a sudden i got an air drop
oh wait yeah i saw you posted you talked
about this it was so
alarming let me tell you why it was a
fellow neighbor okay up late at night so
i have three apartments on my floor
one of them is
someone runs their office out of there
so it's literally only monday through
friday nine to five it's giving us in
our old studio lit literally
the second apartment is a foreign family
they live in like brazil or something so
they're never home
that it's just me
maybe it was someone upstairs or
downstairs
my building is pre-war like it's big
tall like heavy cement ceilings like
and it wasn't just like robert wants to
send claudia a photo it was like a pdf
from like an hp it was giving hacker
it was giving and especially like the
book that i just read was like about
like a security company like in the
hacking and the fbi and all that stuff
so i was like [ __ ] paranoid and i was
like do i accept it or decline it like
that was if i accepted it and it was
some sort of like malware they plug yeah
but i was curious i declined it then i
was up all night just thinking about you
know the very tech savvy home invader or
ghost or squatter living behind my
bathroom mirror
i don't think it's that serious but i do
love your imagination i think either
it was an accident but from where that's
what i'm saying
like you have neighbors like across your
way you're like in your window like
sometimes when i go to air drop
something in my house other things come
up like neighbors and such we live all
very close together in this city it's
really not that crazy i'm surprised it
doesn't happen more often because it's
because it is crazy that's why it
doesn't it was either an accident or it
was a fellow restless sleeper who wanted
to share a note that says you up
and then you would have written back
yeah i can't sleep i was thinking of
maybe sending a selfie being like did
you mean this for me question mark yeah
no and then you guys could have started
a relationship
via airdrop it could have been turned
into a hallmark movie called the airdrop
heiress
or like air dropping into love air drop
dead gorgeous
because the the picture you send was
stunning nicely snatched yeah so then i
was up it was like furthering my
insomnia because i'm like oh there's a
tech savvy home invader in my house from
the genius bar i just don't know why the
home invader would need airdrop to get
into your home maybe your phone
it was suspicious especially maybe it's
a competing podcaster who like wants to
wants to destroy
that's a possibility we want to hack our
instagram and delete all of our viral
clips that's
100 what it was and that's the price of
being at the top of the podcasting game
sorry i don't make the rules and being
so viral so true so shareable so
relatable relatable yeah i think that's
the word people use to describe our show
i think they would say in a serious way
yes yes i think they would say relatable
hilarious creative
completely unique completely not ever
been done before give birth to it throw
it up put it in a blender i think that's
what they would say yeah i think that's
what they do say i think that's what
they do say as well you say how's doo
doo da doo is exhausted from being on
set he was one of the models yesterday
at our spritz photo shoot and he
definitely came back with like a god
complex you know
but so did i so we were very much on the
same page yeah bryce did incredible on
the set he was like born for the
spotlight 100
and i just want to let everyone know
bryce is doing well even though he had
an onion on my instagram story last
night i saw i didn't know that onions
are so toxic for dogs so either you know
that no either it's not so toxic or he
didn't get it i picked it up and he
didn't get it onions and grapes you have
to be really i knew about chocolate and
i knew about chocolate but i didn't know
about onions but bryce seems to be
fine he was these boys got iron stomachs
like nothing phases or he didn't get a
piece of onion because i did pick up
half of it i thought maybe he got the
other half well that's the price of
being a home chef advertiser and his
breath would have smelled like onion
wouldn't it have not really because like
at least theo and i'm pretty sure bruno
is the same like they don't chew they
inhale they swallow yeah like it's not
like he's chewing it up getting all the
onion bits in his teeth and that's what
happens to humans while you have
disgusting breath it's literally a
vacuum
very very true no trace of onion no it's
the price of being hooked on home chef
and now bryce is hooked on home chef as
well so it's my code jackie at 100 to
get 11 free meals
um so yeah that was like my evening of
torture how was you i saw you last night
we had dinner together um even though
you kind of like ambushed me i came over
for dinner and rolled time and there was
no role to be seen and you forced me to
record a podcast episode banking some
content for patreon so that was a nice
little seven o'clock ambush i just
wasn't expecting yeah but i think it was
really nice we did have a delicious meal
then roll did wake up and you were able
to mature him
he did wake up but it was like his
pre-bed
nap so like he was like cranky and like
i was doing all my tricks and he'd give
me like any smiles he was so happy i
have a video on the two of you he's like
enraptured i wasn't feeling like it was
his like best self you know
wow you know now you're coming for a
roll no i'm not coming for a look at you
he was it was right before bed was like
7 45 what did he go about at 8 o'clock
like
i got a small window and it wasn't like
premium rolled because he's like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i gotta sleep i'm gonna tell
him what you said that's fine not
premium rolled you by the way i know
you're his mom but you can admit there's
more premium
hours of rolled than others
my rose is my son what can i say so
annoying and i told you what time to
come over if you wanted premium world
but that was too early for you
well you know what i'm glad that i
didn't because you want to force me to
do two patreons
true so it is what it is i did get some
roll time but i'm expecting a lot of
roll time this weekend because it's my
birthday and i get what i want on my
birthday and this birthday i want to
breastfeed rolled
i just want to see what would happen
that's like kind of like child abuse but
okay no it's not yes it is it's like
you're giving a hungry baby a tit that's
got nothing in it no we wouldn't do it
when he was starving like that's for
sure mean i would do it um like after
he's like had a bottle or something you
know i just want to see like is that
crazy that's an intrusive thought i
think that's child abuse i don't think
it's child abuse i just think it's like
a little psychotic
borderline unethical
borderline yeah
that's like one of my intrusive thoughts
that like i'm getting eerily close to
acting on you know okay what if i just
shove this breast in his mouth you know
oh my god
okay
i don't
you guys let us know in the comments
what you think
let us know drop a comment should
claudio breast feed my yeah okay if we
get to 100 000 subscribers and we get
our plaque i'll breastfeed harry
then you're getting everything you want
that's not how it works
no that's literally how it works no it's
like you have to do something for
getting the thing that you want you have
to do something that you don't want to
do okay what's something that you've
been like asking me to do
oh what's something i've been asking you
to watch yellowstone
yellowstone if i watch all four seasons
of yellowstone i can breastfeed harry
no i was gonna say if we get 100 000
subscribers you have to watch
yellowstone oh you're making this really
hard yeah no now i'm confused like what
are we wagering here
i don't know who wins no i don't get
losers we all do but we all win because
then you watch yellows
you'll be hooked i know i just can't
like i'm having like such tv fatigue for
like the last couple of months me too
but you want to know what's weirdly been
like
i guess this is what like you know
people would call not guilty pleasure
but it's just like a source of comfort
for me like something that i'm really
like just always looking forward to
southern charm yeah like last night i
was up late i if it wasn't southern
charm like if it was beverly hills i
would have gone to sleep but i was like
no i want to watch southern charm like
and when it was over i was like darn i
miss my show well that's so interesting
i'm having definitely the opposite
effect i actually don't like the season
at all i feel like i literally don't
know who anyone is
and i don't know how they're all
connected and it feels like people who
we got invested in are becoming like
friends of madison
like i i actually feel incredibly
confused by the season of southern charm
and also enraged at like literally
the men in this group like being their
worst selves and like just straight up
lying that's the theme of southern charm
since the beginning it's like the men
act in a way that like you would
typically think like girls act like with
their drama yeah like that conversation
between craig and austin like that's
girls in high school no and like craig i
mean austin literally sitting there and
being like i literally don't care like
what you did with naomi well why did you
literally spend all of last week like
talking about it investigating it
thinking about it like you obviously
care yeah so i'm just like annoyed and
the ship is annoying me too like me too
like sorry you can't not not wanting
kids is totally fine
but like to string this girl along and
like i don't know maybe i do like you
obviously don't which is fine just own
it and that's why it was you know what
it was reminding me of and kind of
finally i was able to understand it's
reminding me of like scott disick where
it's like he dates all these really
young girls because not only is he into
young girls but
these are girls who at the time that
they're dating him like
aren't looking to get married aren't
looking to have kids and like after a
year two years when they want something
more the relationship has to end so he's
back to the drawing board but still he's
not going to go out with someone who's
like
30 or 35 or age appropriate because that
person wants a relationship and probably
kids okay but like what if he dated
someone on his level who is like
divorced with kids like that would be
incredibly easy for him she's not gonna
want kids that's true
but could you see like like chef being
someone's stepdad no he doesn't want
that either no he was just bothering me
like a lot and the way like honestly the
disrespect of craig has just like gotten
to a point where i'm [ __ ] done i know
but at least like as viewers
it used to be they would disrespect
craig and put him down it was just sad
period but now like we know craig's on
top so it's like okay you want to shade
him
he's going to go to his store on king
street or right yeah and just roll in
his money yeah and in bed with paige
well we'll talk about southern charm i
just wanted to say like it's a comfort
show for me which i didn't know i'm
happy that you found that yeah i love
that yeah
um
so we've got a great show and we could
jump right in before we do a little
housekeeping housekeeping so the next
two weeks are going to be kind of on and
off with shows because we have so much
going on it was supposed to be like our
summer break but we decided to like fit
in a couple shows just because like
there are some ways to can do shows but
there are some days we can't so next
week we will be doing shows on wednesday
and thursday only in studio but only
wednesday thursday and then the
following week we'll be doing shows
monday tuesday wednesday only yeah we
just got a lot of like business
happenings that like need our full
attention we've got personal stuff like
we just got [ __ ] to do and so we need to
get it out of the way so that we can
come back from the two weeks of
scatteredness scarcity and give it our
100
100 percent so tuesday wednesday of next
week monday tuesday wednesday of the
following week wednesday thursday
[ __ ] sorry okay so we'll see you after
this on wednesday and then from there
we'll let you know what days we'll see
you wednesday thursday monday tuesday
wednesday yeah you know maybe i'll make
one of my little canva pro calendars oh
that's so helpful it really was when you
were on maternity leave those were like
my lifeline also you want to know how
you know we were so busy yesterday we
never even posted our post show picture
yes i did no you didn't no i literally
did i looked so gorgeous
there was no way i was not posting it
let me see that's how busy i was i
didn't even see it yeah but i went to go
our socials on fleek like our reels went
up
i guess because my outfits are so
similar i like i just thought it was the
day before i think we should talk about
that there's been some discussion about
your shirts can you talk to the group
yeah so i thought i established with
everyone that this is just my
uniform until further notice because i
like how
it's comfortable
not too tight they fit these like
collared shirts matching shorts today i
did mix it up um
and it looks professional no i'm not
wearing like sweats every day it's way
too hot to do that yep can't wear like
sweatshirts leggings leggings that's
what i was doing like before but now
i've gotten into these like collared
shirts
and matching shorts and i just feel
really comfortable and i'm just not in a
place right now where i can focus on um
losing weight i just have too much going
on physically
and mentally i don't have like the me
being on a diet takes a lot of mental
fortitude that i do not have right now
because i'm just way too booked and busy
and like
working that i can't and you're
literally raising a child so like it's
fine of course no but i can't dedicate
like the headspace to being on a diet
and i think that's fine like normalize
not being on a diet if you can yeah and
you look great and you just had a baby
and everyone needs to stop i'll get
there when i'm ready and when you know
things calm down for me but i actually
like don't have the time the energy the
resources yeah that's fine physically or
mentally and no time to work out of
course but also physically like i just
feel like i'm do like
my life is so physical right now like i
need food as fuel i can't worry about
like oh i'm still a little hungry like
you didn't fill me up you're
breastfeeding and also
aside from breastfeeding my life is very
physical but also plus breastfeeding it
just makes me voraciously hungry and i'm
not gonna leave myself hungry because
then i have to deal with the mental
aspect of like okay well you know
thinking about like what i'm gonna eat
next
i have no time you have literally no
need for explanation on that front you
look great you're doing great sweetie
thank you stop taking pictures of
yourself your sisters going to jail and
hence wearing like the same comfortable
thing every day that still looks
professional so if you have a problem
with with it then you're coming for new
mamas and mamas get
normalize
wearing the same thing all the time
norma nice having a look that wasn't um
that wasn't english i'm sorry i was like
you were having a uniform no no i said
it i jumbled my words normalize having a
look that's exactly what you said and
that's exactly what i heard really
because sometimes i've been listening to
our podcast like back some clips and
stuff how scary not only do i swallow my
sentences but you really cut me off so
much and i don't notice it when we're
sitting here but then i listen to it i'm
like stick up for yourself girl totally
um again there's really nothing i can do
about that so i do apologize but it's
completely out of my control um and back
to having a look um this is the sixth
color of the amazon set that i own so
i'm with you 100 i don't even know how
many collared shirts and short sets i
own because i do have them from a few
different brands now so sometimes things
may look like they're the same color but
they're different materials and
different brands right so you're not
wearing the same shirt multiple it's
completely different
and that's on
being a style icon yeah
they're not the same blue no
i don't know they're so different
do you know what i'm saying ambulance
yeah and thank you yeah that you no
doubt fished out of a department store
bin
that was chosen selected for you by the
people in this room
such i wish i knew that monologue by
heart like that's a [ __ ] read to
filth like
that real housewives of atlanta level of
reed you should make a tick tock make a
tick tock and that will force you to
memorize it when miranda priestley's
like cerulean like her it's asmr
literally
and she like purses her lips
cerulean
i'm literally going to start an asmr
like pop culture channel
my first video will be this
i would tell gemma that she is a fat can
you see the c word on this podcast yeah
we never have we never have well there's
no sensors okay i'm passionate i wonder
probably our youtube rating like we have
different ads okay oh no but we don't
even do youtube ads i would tell gemma
that she is a fat
runt
who um the shoes she gave me i would
i can't remember the whole thing but you
know what i was gonna say i actually
made a tick tock of it recently and i
memorized it but that was like a couple
weeks ago so i'm like a little let me
think um i would let gemma know that she
is a fat
[ __ ]
and um the shoes that she gave me were
not
the type of shoes that i would wear she
said that they were meant for a
beautiful woman and if that's the case
she should have put him back on the rack
okay
i think gem is just a disgrace
a disgrace to humanity a disgrace to
women who are actually beautiful and
classy
and someone lied to her several times
and told her that she was fly and hot
and sexy and beautiful
and she's nothing like that she's
nothing of the sort
i definitely botched that a little bit i
feel like we were in slam poetry for a
second literally like in the cafe she
would be a poetic genius if she got into
slam poetry tiffany pollard synthia
jesus died for our synthias
that's a good one yeah okay now i feel
ready to get in yeah no you have one
more thing i was gonna say um
ready okay i'm ready to dive into the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of morning toast
i can't wait to jive into that's why
you'll be really good at that i can't
wait to see you do that
dude
i'll be diving but you should die yeah
no i watch great second drive today's
episode is brought to you by all birds
all birds create shoes and clothing that
are better for you and better for the
planet using a revolutionary roster of
premium natural materials like their
popular tree runner sneaker it's called
the tree runner because it's made from
eucalyptus tree fiber a lightweight
breathable and silky soft material
making the tree runner the perfect
everyday shoe for getting the most out
of your sunny days so they're
lightweight and breathable it is a
perfect everyday sneaker for for warm
weather plans whether the summer has you
traveling hiking you need a comfortable
shoe a supportive shoe and a shoe that's
good for their planet bonus they're made
with premium natural materials like
eucalyptus fiber they're designed with a
breathable knit that keeps your feet
cool while you're soaking up the sun and
they're super lightweight makes them
comfortable and the perfect pair to take
along on any adventure find your new
favorite shoes for sunny days and end
upcoming travel at allbirds.com that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com today's episode is also brought
to you by solo stove there's nothing
like a roaring fire to bring you back to
what matters the things that digital
distractions in the frenzy of everyday
life make too easy to forget solo stove
is a travel dream if you appreciate a
nice fire a s'mores moment cuddling up
with your lover you gotta get into solo
stove it is the most premium and
portable
fire pit on the market so you can
upgrade your backyard with a solo stove
fire pit and create story worthy moments
without the fireside fumes it is
stainless steel and it's designed to
regulate airflow and burn more
efficiently so there's little smoke
you'll wonder there's even a fire it's a
perfect catalyst for getting outside and
spending more time with family and
friends and you can build lasting
memories around a solo stove fire pit
they're brilliantly engineered they're
built to last they're easy to light with
a few bits of starter your fire will be
blazing in minutes and of course they're
so confident that you'll love it they
offer a lifetime warranty and a free
30-day return policy we don't even have
backyards and we have a solo stove
because every time we go on vacation we
rent a house we bring the solo stove
because you can never count on like an
airbnb to have the outdoor fire pit of
your dreams and it's so premium it's
easy to pack it's easy to travel with
and if you have a backyard i really
recommend getting one like a porch right
now you can get big discounts during the
solo stove's fourth of july sale use
promo code toast at solostove.com for an
extra ten dollars off that's
solostove.com promo code toast for ten
dollars off on top of their incredible
july fourth sale discounts hurry the
sale ends july 10th which is my birthday
unfortunately
okay our first story some drama in the
ray household addison rey's dad 46 is
allegedly uh having an affair and misled
a 25 year old into having this affair
addison ray's father monty lopez
allegedly carried out a five month
affair with a 25 year old woman named
renee ash in an exclusive interview with
page six renee claims that he led her to
believe their alleged relationship was
more meaningful she said quote
unfortunately he misled me on his
marriage he lied to me he told me that
we were going to be together and have
babies together he even introduced me to
his mom his youngest brother and i
thought we had something real he told me
a story of his marriage that convinced
me that they were apart and in the
process of getting a divorce
uh she alleged that um she broke up with
addison's dad this week after several
girls accused the middle-aged influencer
who boasts 5.4 million followers on
tick-tock that is like the shadiest term
middle-aged influencer please never let
me get to that point
no it's only hitting on a lot of other
girls accused him of hitting on them in
person and even over facetime she said
the last straw the um his girlfriend
said the last draw was when she saw
leaked footage of him alleging allegedly
caressing a girl's backside during a
night out partying sources tell page six
the individual was only 19 years old yes
so that video had went viral on tick
tock and had um all these girls like
posting screenshots of their texts and
like
relationship with monty and what was
like most shocking and probably
embarrassing for monty from this whole
situation is like his text messages like
you thought jeff bezos wanting to get
drunk and read the newspaper was weird
um he is so cringe i'm looking at that
there it's horrible like it's really
like a lack of social awareness
it's a lack of um humanity and it's just
graceful yeah here are some texts
between the two of them they're
horrifying well so she says why are you
so shockingly amazing and sweet please
tell me if it's fake and save me
heartbreak
he said because you deserve it
period
she said i don't didn't mean to send
that i'm sorry if this is weird but i
can't imagine you talking to like this
to sherry
he said we didn't talk he's being like
very short with her
she said whole marriage he said was a
weird relationship she said i can tell
at least we met and mutually haven't
felt this way before he said i love how
you're beautiful and we can have fun and
talk google eyes
she said i love you so much never
expected to be in love ever again
especially now
then she sent a picture of the two of
them in a different exchange saying
can't [ __ ] stop looking at our
pictures miss you so much
he said i love you we headed home i love
this pic we are such the power couple
i'm one hour from the house i'll call as
soon as i have you call yourself a power
couple girly you're not that's one of
those like cringe terms like girl boss
yeah no if you call yourself a girl boss
like you are the boss of nobody not even
yourself nobody nobody spots he said i
wish you sent me pics all day i would
take a sexy pic now send me any new pics
okay so i have to say that i had a very
bizarre um encounter with addison ray's
dad and so not a shred of this is
surprising to me we were at an event
like in the same area
um he had taken off his wedding ring
like made a whole show of it too like
showing everyone i'm taking off my ring
this was like months ago months ago what
was the event um i really wanted where
was it i don't really want to say oh
okay i don't know why like i don't know
no no no no no no no no no no i'm in
trouble i just wish you could like
communicate to me so i could place
myself there okay um no
i'll tell you afterwards um he was being
really inappropriate like so much so
that like it actually um like it was
like a problem with with like a girl
there like it was like it was really
really bad and i just from that moment i
knew he was disgusting and he was like
wasted and like spitting i hate when
people spit when they talk he was just
like a gross drunk guy with like bad
slimy breath and likes thick saliva and
like spitting all over the place um and
he's not like the most gorgeous man in
the world so you can imagine what that
looked like
um so this doesn't surprise me and i
think it's really disgusting and justice
for sherry she's a sweetheart i just saw
her on tick tock making such a cute
fourth of july dessert and this is what
she's coming home to and it also does
make me wonder if like perhaps they've
been aware of monty's like issues in the
past couple months because we've been
talking a lot about how addison feels
like she's taken a very like big step
back from public life
and maybe they knew that this was
brewing and just like we're prepping for
it i don't think so i don't i think the
two are unrelated because addison is a
rising star and like monty's her step
dad like and his creepy behavior is not
gonna dull her shine yeah and if you
ever listen to addison ray's podcast
which i don't think exists anymore but
the first episode they did like it was
her and her mom um doing like a whole
debrief on their family and then the dad
and the family dynamic and like he he
wasn't like a great guy
he left her mom like with the kids for a
really long time and then came back
right before things got good
with addison and stuff so he's like not
he's like a piece of [ __ ]
yeah i'm seeing some of these chef bezos
style texts horrifying uh very
horrifying and there are so many and
it's actually really crazy usually you
know when it rains it pours one person
comes out and then like people come and
share their stories too but considering
they're such online people and that's
also where like these things tend to go
live live
i'm surprised that this is only all
happening now right because it's been a
lot of girls for a lot of time yeah he's
disgusting like literally disgusting and
he's obsessed with writing addison's
coattails and he should know better
because all the things in his life that
afford him the privileges to meet people
like that or because of addison so we
should really just [ __ ] shut up and
protect her yeah but no and i'm sure
it's all over for him and cherry as it
should and maybe this edge cherry to our
list of eligible queens i could see
sherry dating you know jack
sherry and shaq iconic iconic i could
just see her you know dipping her toe
she runs in fabulous circles
i could see like a nice relationship
with another celebrity for her i would
love that maybe sherry and josh groban
crazier things have happened i believe
there's a josh groban concerts like this
weekend
ben was like looking up concerts maybe
to go to this weekend for my birthday if
there is that's what we're doing so you
better no because i think i've pretty
much made up my mind that i want to go
to five seconds of summer this weekend
so josh groban concert near me
near me
i always feel like an actual grandparent
like googling like pharmacies near me
friday july it's saturday july 9th
that's probably
saturday that's also tonight oh in uh at
jones beach
pnc on july no july 9th is pnc tonight
is jones beach you should have and i'm a
pnc person but i'll be here for whatever
you want to do for your birthday no but
i would love if you would take harold to
go see josh groban like i literally sang
josh gorban to harry last night and he
loved it
[Music]
i actually gave such a stunning
performance of a celine dion song to
harry um
last night um when he was hanging out in
your lobby that harry's doorman actually
said that my voice was incredible i
don't even know if i told you this but
on my way out he actually stopped me and
he was kind of like speechless he was
like your voice i'm like no i know and
you weren't even singing good no i
wasn't even trying like you were trying
to like be quiet because you did because
you're in a public place yeah let me see
if there's premium seats there are can
we do this later we're like in the
middle yeah sorry but like i think we
should spend your birthday josh griffin
that's just what i think like for sure
ben would love it and homedale is such a
great venue for sure and i love josh
groban and this is not a slight towards
him at all but like realistically like
the songs that i know he'll probably
play max two of so i'm just gonna you
know more than you think you raise me up
you
are
oh my god it would honestly be such an
emotional experience have we ever seen
him in concert no
and i i know i could go to jones beach
tonight and therefore be here for your
birthday but something about jones beach
is so [ __ ] far and it's like a
concrete jungle and i hate it i think
it's the worst venue and it's a concrete
jungle where dreams are not made up no
it's like everything is the seats are
made of concrete like it's like a
fortress i hate it i'm sorry
don't make me go come on let's go to pnc
actually knowing you i could go to the
concert and your birthday still won't
have star because you're like a late
night 100 night owl
club girly club
i'm gonna look into it wow that just
made my heart flutter you know i
actually recently watched some of our
episodes as well
and i don't think i've really realized
the influence that that character from
hacks has had on me
um i think her name is megan stalter but
she plays kayla the wacky assistant
and her i just feel like i've actually
picked up a lot of her mannerisms like
unknowingly because i also follow her on
tick-tock and every time i'm like
laughing at clips of us i'm literally
being her that's so funny maybe you're
more influenced by her tick tock because
i wa i don't see her tic-tac but i watch
tax and
she grinds my gears oh my god [ __ ]
much i love her she's so funny she is so
funny but
i think it's probably more coming from
tick-tock because
i'm not like sometimes when you do
someone i can feel it in my soul and
it's you're not feeling calm i'm not
feeling the assistant even though
eventually she grew on me because she's
a loyal queen and with and first of all
she put up all of her money to help that
guy but jimmy um
loyalty loyalty is everything really
loyalty is everything you know what else
is everything
timing is everything
gotta watch country strong this weekend
that's how i want to celebrate my
birthday non-stop loop marathon
and then josh gropin and then maybe like
i'll facetime gweneth because
i have her number
there's this guy on tick tock who goes
around um like at beaches and public
places and it's like who's the most
famous person in your cell phone
contacts and it's actually an
interesting question because like
someone's like you know a-rod's cousin
like everyone has like a random and like
i need that to happen to me i'm like
well where do i begin
nicole richie
david foster
gweneth paltrow
you tell me
i don't know
i really don't know
even though like i haven't used those
phone numbers in a few years and i'm
pretty sure they're like celebrities are
always changing their phone numbers
but um i'm not upset or anything i'm
sorry i don't know who the most famous
person in my phone is probably you oh my
god
just an early birthday gift thank you
that's really sweet i really i
appreciate that but i'm still expecting
like a material item as well of course i
have something really big planned i also
got you a present recently did you i
ordered it on amazon but like it was not
prime and it was giving like shady
dealer so i feel like it'll be here in a
month you want to hear something crazy
remember how i told you guys i needed to
order my post-natal pills so yesterday i
finally went to order them and they're
like temporarily unavailable because
like the ingredients are just not
available but they're like you know
supply chain it's like a prime item
they're i don't go to some like they're
indeed they're nature made you know no
they're supply chain ones on amazon
supply chain nothing works in this
country there's nothing on the shelf i
can't get anything i need a supply chain
anytime you can't get anything
everyone's just like supply chain and
then you're just supposed to accept that
but like chalking it up can we
investigate what happened to the supply
chain let's get it on it's been working
for hundreds of years and you know what
i am and it's working really strongly
and in this way for decades and i'm an
understandable queen like of course
coveted will derail some things but like
it's like
by the way and kovid was like popping
you know for a year and a half and the
supply chain was fine yeah no i have i
have something they'll say they'll say
it was like staggered right i have some
theories on the supply chain and i'm
just saying if that [ __ ] doesn't get
her act together soon like
i'm not gonna do anything but i'll be
upset no but like it's two things one
stop blaming everything on the supply
chain and fix it no or like is that just
like a thing people say no that's my
second thing is there are some things
like dana was telling me her uh like
wedding photographer her photos were
going to be late and he was like supply
chain and it's like you have your camera
in your mouth or your computer right so
there's there are people who are blaming
things against the supply chain because
you can no since 2020 like we all have
like a slew of excuses for many things
even when i was talking about yesterday
my show titanic being canceled um
coven like what
it's not an acceptable excuse like get
an understudy no so like they're just
like all these things and it's actually
nice for like humans like oh i can't go
to work i've covered but like you know
you're fine like yeah or you could even
be like i was exposed i just need to
change right right or like oh no sorry i
didn't get the report in like my paper
and my printer couldn't fill because of
supply chain like right it's nice for us
mortals like to have like some things to
fall back on for excuses but like for
the infrastructure of the country like
get it together yeah agreed two separate
things i also saw like kate middleton
couldn't go to an event because she was
exposed to covet and it's like
she's tired i believe that's a lie and
you know what that is what uh the one of
the very small blessings that came out
of covid i think like
she
a forever excuse she shouldn't go to the
event like she's probably tired and
she's a mom of three like let that [ __ ]
go home yeah but now we all have an
excuse that's fine you don't even have
to lie and say that you have coveted
because i'm exposed yeah but exposed 100
are you ready for our next story
yeah i really am kim kardashian's on the
cover of allure she says she'd do
anything to look and feel youthful kim
is laying leaning into her blonde alter
ego hard she says i have a different
energy when i'm blonde i'm a totally
different person i'm sassier i'm more
confident as a blonde that's not to say
that a brunette kim is any less powerful
though in her opinion brunette kim is a
boss add long nails to the equation and
she has what she refers to as [ __ ] boss
energy i like that she like associates
different phases of her life and like
who she's gonna
channel
based on her hair yeah but just so
doesn't change her hair too much so
these are like concrete personalities
you know i saw a lot of coverage on this
allure cover
also just talks about aging and what
she's done and
her philosophy on trying to stay
youthful and i think a lot of this is
probably like not more not in like such
a in a more subtle way like a
has a lot to do with skin you know like
just making her like the face of
youthfulness
and honestly like
one of the things i love about kim is
like the fact that she's like 40 you
know it's like
she's literally the sexiest woman alive
a bombshell and like for years like you
have to be 21 to do that and it's like
no one on the planet is sexier and kim
is also 40 and had four kids like i
don't know i just
i don't really like this like angle like
this youthfulness like i'm
i always want to look my best like and i
want to be like tight and right forever
but like this obsession with youth is
like
it's not my favorite thing honestly
i hear what you're saying i think she is
positioning herself for skin and i do
want everyone to know i use skin every
night and it's great and i love it and
sometimes like i always switch off what
i use because sometimes i mean they're
feeling lazy or i like to like keep my
skin on its toes like you don't know
what's coming is it going to be vitamin
c serum is it going to be lemaire is it
going to be skin like you need to be
prepared and i'm going to blast all my
rosacea
but like skin is every day when i go to
do my face i'm like when i go to do my
skincare i'm like my skin looks good i
should do what i just did so i do skin
and it's amazing i believe it for sure
but back to this positioning i agree now
she's sort of
taking this angle of like i'm obsessed
with looking young i'll do anything i
can to look young while still minimizing
her reliance on the real stuff she says
she's never had filler in her nose or in
her lips or her cheeks that right now
she has a little bit of botox but she's
getting over botox so she's gonna let it
like fizzle out but like
i'm sorry lay people don't look like
this at 41.
what did she have a facelift if she
really has no filler and a little bit of
botox like then what is it yeah i feel
like she's never lying in the interview
because the interviewer is asking do you
have botox or do you have filler to
those things maybe she doesn't have
those things right now yeah what do you
have where can i get it yeah and also i
don't really believe like every person
who's famous owes us a detailed
explanation of what they do plastic
surgery-wise like i think this
expectation that like every woman has to
say exactly what she had done i don't
need to know what everyone has had done
but if you're talking about
the process of staying young and some of
the things that you do then now that the
can of worms is open i want to see all
the worms agreed i just
maybe it has to do with the fact that
she's like dating a younger guy but i
feel like her recent like obsession with
youth is like
it just doesn't feel so kim to me i feel
like she's so proud of like the years
under her belt and all that she's
accomplished and like i don't know i
just like and allure to me is like kind
of like a tacky magazine
i was just like you were just like on
vogue we were watching you on keeping up
and sports illustrated i'm like oh lord
that's like being on lucky magazine like
i know but like allura's beauty and i
think this is beauty this is all for sk
yeah it is and so this is her approach
to aging she says she's at peace with
not being perfect um she said i hate my
hands they're wrinkly and gross and also
you can't fix hands she said but i've
lived life and i've changed so many
diapers with these hands and i've
snuggled my babies with these hands so
i'm okay with them getting older doesn't
mean that i won't strive for perfection
but you get to a point where you're like
okay my health is more important than
anything else but even though she knows
the aging process is natural it doesn't
mean that she won't do everything in her
power to look and feel young for as long
as she can she said it's hard to explain
because i'm at peace but i would still
do anything to look and feel useful yeah
and i think there's also something to be
said for the fact that kim probably
leads an extremely healthy lifestyle
plant-based working out and all that
definitely contributes to how you look
like when i'm 40 i'm gonna be old and
haggard because all i do is drink and
eat poorly like and that's on
the consequences of your actions she
also doesn't drink she doesn't right she
doesn't drink i think there's a lot of
things she does outside of like skin
care dermatology that contribute to her
looking really good and i think that's a
thing in hollywood where
a lot of the women look younger than
they are because of all the things that
they do but also for like 20 years
they've led like no meat no alcohol clue
green juice cleanse clean and that
totally helps i'm not saying it's
everything but it's definitely a factor
like you are what you eat
yeah
you are what you eat that feels like one
of those like fat phobic sayings i don't
think so well it does it's very literal
you know like you'll look like how much
you eat right
but
in this you know
context who she sends yeah yeah like you
are like if you if you're if you process
your skin won't be glowing but if you're
like on an all [ __ ] even when you did
your dumb ass juice cleanse like you did
have like bright skin and white eyes
if you eat healthy you'll feel healthy
yeah and so it's definitely a huge part
of like why women in hollywood look
younger than they are but it's also
all everything else that they're you
know have access to yeah so this
obsession with youthfulness is just not
my favorite kim era but i support her
nonetheless and we'll still take a
bullet for her so yeah and i'm a big fan
of skikkin and i thought the photos from
this
look were
beautiful from this shoot and it was
different i feel like we just had this
conversation it's like the same kind of
like
looks for the last couple months like
leggings lycra
spandex and this is different and i
thought she looked great she's just like
covered in hair yeah like look at this
shirt it's made of hair yes i saw that
and i also did like they had a one shot
in the spread of um her glam team yeah
so mario and chris got in there which is
probably really fun for them yeah and
because it's a beauty magazine and she's
the glam girl it's pertinent to the
situation i loved it love it okay next
up another kardashian story because
kylie is on tick tock clapping back at
people who are making [ __ ] up and i'm
really living for it yes so kylie jenner
accused a tick-tock user of lying for
attention after he claimed to have heard
her son crying while delivering an
instacart order
on
thursday uh she posted a video of
herself making a sandwich and we all
talked about subway sandwiches
yes and then someone on tick tock said
that he thinks that he delivered the
ingredients ingredients to her house
because he had a bag full of these
ingredients and he said he's an
instacart driver yeah he came through
the gate and he heard a baby crying he
drove through a river and he believes
that it was kylie's house and she put it
under a fake name that's what he said
and so she commented saying the lying
for attention rubs me the wrong way
sorry i did not order this myself he was
tipped through the app lied to about
seeing my son
about seeing through my windows and
hearing my son cry
so
she's saying like i couldn't tell if she
was saying it's not true or it was him
and he was tipped through the app no i
think she was saying it's not true
because she also said that he's talked
about a river and that she has no river
on her property yeah and let's say for
argument's sake that this
instacart driver did deliver to kylie
to be in someone's home and like near
their kids and then like blow it up on
social media it's just like so tacky and
like so
i think evident of like the culture we
live in where like everyone's obsessed
with like blowing up celebrity spots
like no matter the cost so let's say it
was him and she ordered under a fake
name and he got the ingredients whatever
um
i think i feel like he could have made a
video and been like i think i just
delivered to kylie like that was so
exciting like to i don't know like it
just feels kind of icky to me beyond
icky to be in someone's home and like
blow it up with everything you saw right
that's so even if that was the if it was
true
it's
are they right
and i think unethical and also
indicative of this culture where like
everyone just like wants to go viral and
have their moment and like catch a
celebrity hey look at me yeah
like at what cost right and so i agree
with you oh my god i just i think i
delivered to kylie like that's pretty
cool as opposed to being like i think i
heard her son crying like
the [ __ ] yeah like oh kylie's only
person who has a baby
and by the way i just have a hard time
believing kylie wanted a sandwich and
instacarted food like i just know her
house is oh wait the kardashians you see
their kitchens like they have everything
at all times like it's not like she
needed you know a fillet of salmon or
she sent someone to the store yeah it
was just like basic grocery items that
most people have in their house bread
lettuce mayo turkey like yeah who knew
that this sandwich would cause such a
ruckus you know what i did yeah i saw it
i was like the world can't handle this
sandwich and honestly like this is why
kylie stays the [ __ ] away from us like
she can't make a sandwich without
someone claiming like
they made the sandwich you know right
it's just like everyone's taking credit
for her sandwich she can't make a
sandwich in peace
she should or open up a sandwich shop
kylie's
kai way
kaiway
it's my way or kaiway
they should open a restaurant
i love that like kylie called this guy
out but then it just like sets a
precedent that you could like make some
[ __ ] up and be called out by a celebrity
and you get attention right and then
also i'm sure she feels about it like
you know if i call out this person then
i have to call out every other untruth
and if i don't call out those untruths
then people might think that they're
true but you know what sometimes you
don't have to set a precedent and you
just gotta shut a [ __ ] up no sometimes
you just like do what you [ __ ] feel
yeah
and not worrying about like what
precedent does this said for my brand
like what this means for the next time
just
let them know yeah let them know so i'm
glad that kylie's sticking up for
herself me too and i hope this doesn't
stop i hate this trend and it's not
going anywhere anytime soon and like
it's people just like live for you know
talking about like their celebrity
encounters making stuff up as we know
you know yeah taking a picture of a
celebrity when they see them putting in
none do one it's just like
a grade
it's like it's we've reached a new level
of like obsession with celebrities and
literally look at us getting out of bed
every day obsession with the celebrity
it's about how that exchange benefits
you yeah and puts down the the other
person sure but it could be good good
bad whatever but it's how that benefits
you oh so and so ate at this restaurant
that i was at don't forget i was there
no and just i think it's like this whole
thing of taking things out of context
like
oh i saw shawn mendes at a restaurant
and he was so rude really were you
sitting with him talking like you don't
[ __ ] know shut up yeah and so it's
just like this obsession with
what you think you saw and you saw
nothing right but also with knowing
things first like just being in the know
and
even when people like write in like oh i
know that this person is pregnant yeah
so so you know no somebody so
somebody had messaged us
when um katherine foste what's her name
kevin mcphee what's her name mickey
foster kevin mcphee foster was pregnant
um because they had
been in the waiting mcfoster they'd been
in the waiting room at their
gynecologist together
um and that just felt like and they dm'd
it to us
that just felt like a huge breach of
hipaa even though she wasn't a nurse
like it's just a violation of humanity
yeah and it's just like okay so
she's pregnant and you know so what but
i also feel like it's taken us
mj time mj
like we've come around to this
conclusion like maybe just like growing
up and having like experiences and and
now i can see it as like okay so you
know something you're the first person
to know something who the [ __ ] cares
yeah no that lesson came to me in like
such a humbling and honestly like
earth-shattering way mercedes javi who
like now is one of my really good
friends but at the time she was just
like a reality star who i
loved and i got like a very
reliable tip that she was pregnant so i
posted it on our instagram um and she
literally commented like no i'm not and
she was but she had like an exclusive
with people and she wasn't ready yet and
like i was just being this annoying
[ __ ] [ __ ] barging in on her moment
like right
and in that moment i actually i was at
an ed sheeran concert when she commented
i remember it i was like oh my god i'm
literally like a piece of [ __ ] rat
i'm literally that reporter from the
hannah montana movie like i'm disgusting
i have no code of ethics piece of [ __ ]
rad so and i never did it again like
it's not our [ __ ] business and like
yeah you're right so so you get to post
it on your instagram first we used to
and then what we use i feel like we used
to be those people though that it's like
we want to be the first to know if
something happened we want you guys to
have come and found it out from us and
it's like not only is it like okay so
say you found it out from us like
cool
but you're also like that's someone's
private personal business yes that also
happened to be like last year with kylie
and tre i mean not kylie with travis and
courtney's engagement somebody was on
the beach and sent me a picture
everybody was on the beach yeah and it
wasn't really private but and i posted
it on my instagram i just felt icky
about it so i deleted it right and they
did wind up announcing it really soon
and it wasn't the sort of thing that
they were trying to keep private but
it's just like icky so what yeah and i
feel like i'm i'm at least hope and
think i'm getting much better at that
like i don't want to be that rat no i i
don't think we have any sort of
inclination to do that anymore and you
know what it does take some time and
maturity to get to that place yes i
think maybe everyone's just catching up
hopefully one day we'll come around to
that is what i'm hoping yeah yeah
they're going to get on our level soon
that's what we're saying of emotional
maturity get on our level that's the
takeaway from this whole episode title
title
um before we keep going i just want to
say that today's episode is brought to
you by kitsch
they say that hair care is a new
skincare but there's one brand that's
taking it to the next level with a cult
like following kitsch has created some
game changing essentials that beauty
enthusiasts swear by from satin
pillowcases to time-saving towels
kitchen knows hair care doesn't stop in
the shower so they're offering
game-changing time-saving beauty
essentials for your hair skin and body
whatever your budget whatever your skin
type or your hair type kitch believes
that you deserve little indulgences at
affordable prices starting morning noon
and night
so some of their best sellers include a
lot of products that we have first off
the satin pillowcase like i wake up
in a hotel or when i don't have a satin
pillowcase like with a [ __ ] rat's
nest on my head and i never realized
like i just thought i'm like a crazy
sleeper no girl get a satin pillow case
like it will literally help and it also
helps your face
i mean like your skin
um so the satin is vegan and cruelty
free it's not like silk which was made
from silk worms they're great for your
hair and skin while you sleep they've
been proven to you know decrease lines
maintain your hair they also make
shampoo and conditioner bars which is
part of their bottle free beauty so it's
way better for the environment like you
would use a bar of soap use a bar of
conditioner so smart like genius they
also have heatless satin curling rollers
so no more heat damage i've seen a lot
of videos on talk of people like
literally throwing away their curling
irons to
do heatless curls i see them on reels
yeah you see them six months later um so
kitsch is
offering a great discount on their
products i really love the satin
pillowcase um the shampoo and
conditioner bars are great as well and
they're offering you 30 off your entire
order at my kitch.com toast that's 30
off anything and everything at my kitsch
m-y k-i-t-s-c-h
dot com slash toast my kitsch.com toast
for 30 off your order
love it okay our next story i know i
said yesterday that nothing in the
housewives world could even shock me
anymore but something has
heather gay and meredith marks join jen
shaw in new york city for her upcoming
trial heather gay and meredith marks are
part of the shaw squad in new york city
while she's here for her trial let me
just say one thing this is why real
housewives of salt lake city is not that
[ __ ]
the women are so finicky so flaky go so
below the belt with one another and then
the next episode not even the next
season it's like a clean slate it's so
difficult to follow they have no loyalty
to anyone not even to themselves and
that's why this franchise is not what it
should be so what you're saying is they
don't have scruples
thank you they have no have you know
scribbles
the railhouses of salt lake city star
supported their co-star gen shot by
traveling with her to new york city less
than two weeks before her upcoming fraud
trial in manhattan federal court the
three bravo liberties whose friendship
may come as a surprise to viewers yeah
touched down in the big apple earlier
this week and have been documenting
their many adventures together in one
instagram story posted by heather the
threesome posed for a selfie in a dark
restaurant heather captioned it my coven
they're just like doing a million things
together promoting books taking pictures
of each other and i do not understand
the meredith mark right because i think
of all the women she's probably the most
principled
and this is not something a principled
person would do no and her
criticism of jen has seemed the most
final there's no coming back from it
even if like not even like
we'll ever be best friends but can we
even get to a place of friendship i
don't know now she's
part of shaw squad at the trial such a
bad look and honestly i don't really
know a lot of the legal stuff around
jen's trial but i just know like you
don't
get put on trial by like the u.s
government without
going to jail for some amount of time
yeah it's this isn't like a criminal
case where it's like
you know innocent until proven guilty or
like there's a jury like
when the u.s government is the one
indicting you like because they have
proof right like congress they don't
just like go out on a limb yeah also
like what's also confusing is jen
there's a picture of her here like
wearing gucci sandals and a gucci purse
that are this season gucci
so where is that money coming from like
remember when she took money from her
mother
who was a school teacher for lawyers so
like where is she getting this renewed
money i'm sure she's still making money
from the show and on instagram but she
has to pay her retainers and if she has
money to spare like she should be paying
her mom back now that's actually really
true and it's this season because it
could be fake
i don't know just to keep up her
appearances no it's hard for herself
from a photo that little purse that is
so [ __ ] cute on the yeah for sure
and i feel like fakes don't really come
out like when the new collection comes
out it's like next year these are gucci
sandals that are gucci and they're this
season no that's definitely an
interesting point you're very
detail-oriented i just was just looking
at these sandals because i think they're
so cute it's like the same
thing it's same [ __ ] different year like
always been confused about her finances
even now yeah but now like she could
post a picture like this look at this
picture where she looks like you know
yeah she's dressed in the nines you
could argue that that's all old stuff
that she bought prince but you're saying
it's a new season i get it when it's
this season yeah make it make sense i
mean make any of this make sense make
the meredith part make sense yes i am
looking forward to like getting some
kind of closure from the trial i feel
like we've been talking about it for a
while and it got pushed back it was
supposed to be in march so
like let's see like she's playing this
card of being framed
let's see she's brain bridged literally
yeah stu is
testifying against her like it's not
going well no so in two weeks it starts
so we will be
down at the courthouse no it's literally
going to be like just kidding it's going
to be
like a trial that everyone's watching
whatever it's going to be televised
was none of theresa did teresa go on
trial no i feel like she took a deal
yeah so we never played out in court
yeah but they do say they remember how
galen wasn't televised because they say
like federal trials aren't televised
it's like it varies per case i think
it's what state you're in like
it will benefit gen benefit jen greatly
if it's not talented of course she's not
exactly because if it is televised like
it's going to be the new amber and
johnny yeah and she's not exactly
how she doesn't have a good track record
of making herself look good
and she's not a professional i mean she
is a professional con woman i guess
allegedly and they actually i think she
would probably want it to be trial
because she'll probably have her look
like she can put she can maybe try and
win over people's hearts and minds
knowing that people will be watching but
i think it will behoove her if it's not
yeah
so very curious to see what the outcome
of this trial is and i don't understand
these two morons tagging along
yeah no
truly i understand heather no every time
i think like heather can't get like a
lower grade in my book she does
something moronic like this yeah but
this doesn't surprise me heather has
decided you know whatever jen is guilty
of even if she is guilty heather doesn't
care but like meredith up until this
point has been incredibly scrupled yeah
and it's confusing when someone goes
from scribbled to scrupulous they lose
their scruples they can't find them
right maybe she's just lost maybe
are you ready for our fifth and final
story yes ma'am someone we've been
talking about a lot this week hayden
panettieres ex brian hickerson confirms
that they've split permanently got it so
this is in line with her press press
this week her new
start fresh start
she is no longer with brian who is the
guy that is that the father of her no no
okay
this is the guy that they were like
brawling in the parking lot with people
and there's been a few other incidents
of like violence right so he was catched
by paparazzi this week and they were
they asked him how him and hayden were
doing to which he responded just you
know friends they asked more directly if
they were still together and he said no
absolutely not okay good i mean he's
obviously i think like the timeline of
when he entered her life was when a lot
of things started to go bad for her like
just two people who aren't right for
each other but i did want to mention
that i watched a little clip of her
people magazine interview where she
shared the fact that her daughter lives
um
between germany and ukraine
and she doesn't live
with her daughter she doesn't live in
the same country as her daughter and she
was like on the verge of tears talking
about how like she talks to her and her
daughter still loves her and she like
doesn't understand why and she's just so
grateful that her kid is so great it was
like so emotional
um and i feel like it was really brave
because i think like a lot of people she
would like
they would be wrong for but a lot of
people would judge her for like letting
her child live in another country with
her dad but hayden like knew her own
limits and her faults and like let
her dad have full custody um and i
thought it was like really
i was i didn't know any of this and i
was like shocked by it and also like
really um
in awe of the bravery to speak on it
because it's so personal like it's
really nobody's business like what the
custody but it was really shocking
oh wow she did she she looked beautiful
and like she was like on the verge of
tears the entire interview it was really
interesting to like get an update on her
oh i want to watch that clip because i
didn't realize that she voluntarily yes
like she knows i think she's just been
struggling like since she gave birth to
her daughter she was very public about
her postpartum like really bad
postpartum and it just spiraled
from there with like bad choices and bad
men in her life um
and so yeah she
i believe willingly
wanted what was best for her daughter
and that wasn't being with her which
must be like literally the hardest
decision on the planet to make totally
and this week of talking about hayden
penn tier i was making me think about
the week when we talked about like
jessica simpson every day because she
was writing her book and i and i think
it's time for a hayden book oh my god by
the way
a hundred percent i don't know if she's
there yet like emotionally or mentally
but when she gets there and it seems
like she's definitely on her way
especially if she's no longer with this
guy if she's like being able to sit down
and talk about really hard things and
talk about addiction in the rear view
mirror oh my god yes that would be an
amazing book an amazing book i love that
publishers get to it start writing some
offers that's a great idea
and those are the first five feel as
though you need to know them it's
actually pretty juicy for friday i don't
want you to get too excited but should
we uh recap southern charm ooh i'm
feeling so comfortable southern charm is
brought to you by zoc dock a free app
that shows you doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance and are
available when you need them sock doc
helps you find every specialist under
the sun whether you're trying to
straighten your teeth fix an achy back
get your mold checked out or anything
else zocdoc has you covered their mobile
app is as easy as ordering a ride or to
a restaurant or getting a delivery to
your house you could search find and
book doctors with a few taps go to
zocdoc.com to find the right doctor
that's right for you book an appointment
in person or remotely whatever works for
your schedule every month millions of
people are using zocdoc we are two of
them it's our go-to whenever we need to
book and find a quality doctor it can be
really hard to find like good
specialists and doctors when you don't
have
one and like going online can be like
overwhelming so for zocdoc just to
streamline it also lets you book see if
they take your insurance you'd have to
call and be like hi do you take my plan
like it's just easy and if you hate
talking to people on the phone like it
minimizes a lot of torture
that's me go to zocdoc dot com toast
download the doc doc app for free and
then start your search for a top rated
doctor today many are available within
24 hours that's
z-o-c-d-o-c dot com toast zoc doc dot
com slash toast
thank you all right southern charm
um
[Music]
the pinnacles of the episode for me were
them discovering madison's engagement of
course and it reminded me like how
bizarre it was that she announced it on
amazon live yeah and i'm surprised they
even gave amazon live that much
press one saying amazon live multiple
times and two feeding the stream into
the show like they must have some sort
of they had to like license it or
something yeah because usually they have
to like block stuff out um but i did
think it was interesting when craig
broke the news to um
austin and he was like
madison is about to go live and i think
maybe announce that she's engaged and he
checked his watch
almost like he knew that she had a live
stream at two o'clock like he was like
obsessed with her schedule like i just
felt like the fact that he looked at his
watch was really suspicious justin yeah
okay like oh is it two o'clock already
time for her stream
like it was just it was a weird thing to
do i didn't notice it i was like
perplexed by it yeah confused it's
really crazy that like we just heard
that she's in a new relationship and
that they're getting engaged at the same
time i do wish madison was a cast member
in her own right because it seems like
she has a lot going on and also like she
is just television gold like yes every
scene that she's in she's a scene
stealer she always has the best
one-liners and she is so polarizing and
that's what people love and i think
there are a lot of people obviously who
don't like madison but there are a lot
of people who love her
i really like her i think she's great on
television and i think she's just like
herself and
i want more madison she should be a
full-time cast member she gives so much
and by the way i thought she
really put vanita in her place when she
needed to that was so surprising
because she wasn't just being like an um
indulgent friend enabling her friend's
poor bad behavior like usually when you
sit down with your friend you just like
agree with them especially if you
weren't there but two the girl that they
were going for is austin's new
girlfriend so she's all austin's dated
girl that he's interested in so you
would think that madison would like be
excited that i think that's coming for
her but the fact that she stood up for
her i was just like just when you think
you know madison nope and by the way she
was 100 right like vanita why do you
care about literally any of this not one
bit of it has to do with you and i think
veneta is just fueled by her hatred of
catherine but so she's acting just a
little irrational and i was she was like
bothering me and i couldn't put my like
foot on it or something
making this first of all it wasn't even
a big thing between naomi and uh
and at the end of the day they're
talking about a third person it's not an
issue between naomi and olivia it's an
issue between naomi and catherine so
they're having this like third person
exchange and then vanita's coming and
she doesn't like the way that they're
talking about their issue with someone
else and it's like there's too many
cooks in the kitchen and it totally
escalated it it's not a big big deal she
was just asking a question and i don't
think naomi cared that much and as
madison said naomi's very smart she can
stand up for herself right like she
doesn't need like venita she doesn't
need backup i think veneta is getting
more involved in the storyline now so
she wants to have like a hand and
everything which i totally get but it's
making her look just like a little
annoying and thirsty yeah and i also
found it interesting because i just
caught up on last week's episode when
she was talking about her business of
influencing and i really appreciated the
respect she put on influencing like it's
not just snapping a photo and moving on
with your day like it's a full-fledged
business that you can make a lot of
money from but i was shocked when the
way she was talking about making seven
figures a month and i was like how many
followers does she have she's 80 000
followers which is probably more than
she had when she filmed that because
right just getting followers yeah and so
i was just confused how like you run a
seven figure a month business with
eighty thousand well did she say she
makes seven figures a month or that you
can make seven things it sounded like in
the past she had made seven figures not
consistently that would be amazing that
was just surprising yeah because that's
a lot of money to make even when you
have millions of followers yeah every
month so i was confused by that um but i
did appreciate a lot of the respect she
was putting on oh for sharing she's
great style and i'm very lucky and her
content is premium like i went on her
instagram like she takes it serious and
i respect that yeah also like that scene
was from two episodes ago i think where
benita and naomi are playing tennis and
they just yes so stunning yeah like
that's what we come to the show for yeah
and her cloth like she's premium um but
i think she's having a hard time finding
her footing as an official cast member
because in past seasons she's just kind
of been like someone's sidekick yeah and
now it's her moment and i think she
wants to make the most of it and she's
like not sure what to do with it yeah
and she's taking i just taking it out on
the wrong and he'll see
next week also what's so funny is
madison says i have a client who would
let us use their house and i think next
week it's patricia's house i thought she
had another client that she was another
house and i'm like that's really nice
that clients of course elect
last season she had a client or
something who used that big house with
the treehouse and it was on the water
yeah it was beautiful yeah that's true
so maybe it's not patricia's no but it
patricia's there next week and it looks
like patricia's house
we'll see why wouldn't she just say
patricia by the way sad about whitney's
dad and i feel like have they ever
spoken about him no i found that whole
thing interesting like so
those are the pictures of patricia
patricia
is that woman and she is the seven
husbands of patricia
and
as much as we're hard on her and her
role in this show
give us patricia's history give us a
documentary like i just found those
pictures to be fascinating and she was
selling art like she really has lived a
thousand lives and that little sneak
peek was really interesting and it's all
led her to be like this woman in this
house with this wealth and eating
mcdonald's in her bentley and her tray
table it's true and how did she get here
no we need like a full thing yeah
we need like a book you know who's um
turning into like one of my favorite
like random supporting characters
pringle oh yeah he's like i felt like we
got a little too much of him last season
like i don't think he has what it takes
to be like a full-on
cast member and i feel he likes to
switch places with vanita almost and
she's
good for it and he's not and i think
that this is better for him yeah because
he just seems like a guy that's easy to
get along with but i think when we saw
too much like it was too much yeah no it
was like i wasn't i was like please stop
yes also
you just said pringle who was i
oh you know who else i like chef's
cousin oh chef's cousin i like her too i
like her too and i like shep's
girlfriend yeah me too a little bit
she's not what i thought um
i guess we got a little bit of her last
season but i i like that she you know
knows that soon what she wants and that
like she's gonna have to go her separate
ways to shop but they're still together
today and like chef just settle down
it's really not that scary no it's not
like when what's scarier is like being
you yeah of course but for me like and
this is what i say sometimes during dear
toasters like guys who are in
full-fledged relationships living with
women who are afraid to get married like
literally nothing changes i can totally
understand being afraid and not ready to
have kids that's huge
settling down into a marriage is
literally what you're doing now but like
a little better like i'll never
understand that
so shep has just been bothering the [ __ ]
out of me like i'm i'm so over him and i
feel like he's long extended his like
playboy thing to a point where it's not
cool or funny it's sad you know who he's
becoming thomas yeah what's also crazy
is that thomas and catherine are still
in a custody battle even after
everything that came out about him in
the last few years i thought all of that
meant like he literally sexually
assaulted their nanny and she pressed
charges i thought that all meant that
like catherine should have surprised
their children when i heard she had that
only every other weekend every other
weekend that must [ __ ] torture her
with thomas all that other time terrible
terrible and then catherine and caleb
yeah i'm honestly like
so annoyed with catherine like
i'm upset for caleb but like you know
what blessing like she's extremely
chaotic and toxic i know but then just
seeing their dynamic with how close she
is with him with his mom just made me
realize there's so much more to their
relationship that we don't know that we
don't see and like
that her kids love his mom and like i
you can't stay in a relationship for
someone i am now sad and when caleb was
first on the phone with his mom talking
about catherine and we didn't know yet
that they were close i was like oh my
god i can only imagine what caleb's mom
thinks thanks
yes
and then to hear that they're like even
closer and it just goes to show there's
even layers of catherine that we
probably don't know
that you know because the person that
you would see on the show like it's like
oh how is she getting along with anyone
however her driving in the pouring rain
on the phone without looking up at the
wheel like she was giving me such bad
anxiety anxiety the rain was insane she
was so fidgety with her phone she wasn't
even looking at the road yeah it was
driving me nuts yeah me too also she was
driving over to craig's apparently
because they had a conversation where
she's wearing that outfit and we only
get it in a flashback yes good call
anyways
i'd like to be caleb's mom given what
we've seen about caleb and catherine in
just the last two three episodes um and
i will be sad to see them i will be sad
to see them split up because it seems
like there's just
you know a closeness that we don't know
about yeah
those meatballs did look good though
that she was making yeah and it was a
sad that nobody ate up morsel
devastating but what did she put the
meatballs on i would have assumed rice
but it had a more creamy like polenta
consistency maybe it was an orzo risotto
yeah
interesting nobody even ate it um what
it wasn't really that crazy of an
episode i feel like it was like a pause
like before something big yeah well i
guess because caleb and catherine are
gonna break up right like i really like
madison's engaged she's having that
girl's
tea time
at her client's house next week and it
looks like there benita and olivia are
going to get into it and vanita and
catherine
yeah vanita she needs to go straight to
the source like you obviously [ __ ]
hate catherine stop being mad at
everyone around her and just be mad at
catherine yeah
for whatever reasons or go for it yeah
but she's making yourself look just like
a little messy by taking her anger out
on catherine on literally everyone else
yeah i'm like olivia who's so new to the
group where it's like
and she whatever she said even though
it's like kind of dumb like her
intentions were earnest in naomi's house
yeah i don't have i don't have an issue
with what she said it felt like she was
actually on a fact-finding mission and
that she's not just going to write
catherine off she clearly like knows
catherine even a little bit and so it's
like let me give this person a shred of
the benefit of the doubt no and you know
what no matter what the situation is on
a reality show and like everyone's
talking [ __ ] about someone and then one
person is like it's not really fair to
like talk about a situation when the
person's not here even if i hate the
person like i actually respect that
mentality like it's not fair to debrief
and like pick apart a situation about a
person who's not in front of you so like
one person standing up and then getting
like
attacked
it's it
they were like
we they were saying afterwards like i
don't want to seem like we were ganging
up on olivia like that's actually what
you were all doing yeah so yeah no and i
i liked um
was it olivia who said like whenever
there's a situation where everyone's
against one person like i
who said that i don't know
madison
talking about olivia
yeah yeah yeah that was a nice moment
yeah it's like everyone just chill chill
anyways it's good i love the gang i love
you
oh my god i love you too the next time
you guys see me i'll be an old maid old
maiden type of shoes
um and the next time they see us it'll
be wednesday right it'll be wednesday
it'll be hump day and that's really
exciting so just a reminder the next two
weeks are scattered two episodes next
week wednesday and thursday in studio
regular stuff the week after that monday
tuesday wednesday jackie and i have some
things we got to do and then after that
we will be back on our regularly
scheduled programming thank you for your
patience
we love and appreciate you until death
do us part thank you so much for
listening to the morning toast the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fafsa stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're listening to this on
youtube
subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as podcasts anywhere podcasts
can be found out spotify i just stitch
your public radio i really can't watch
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the more you chose to
leave a five-star review please we could
use them about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are have an amazing weekend
stay safe don't forget to wish me a
happy birthday on sunday and i will be
accepting um cash gifts only have a
great day bye bye
you